the movie you wrote is the complication
and your family experience right
i mean the movie yes it's not
autobiographical in the sense that there
are things that never ever happened and
there's a lot of shifts to characters
that i had to lean into to tell a story
appropriately
but yeah my father died my father of
blessed memory died seven years ago
and um there's a a very specific year of
mourning uh which i think we talked
about um and after that i started
writing and i didn't think oh i'm going
to make a movie i thought i just need to
write i'm a writer and that's where
these feelings are going to go and i
really sat on it for a while and
eventually showed it to a couple people
close to me and
here we have this sweet little
independent film with dustin hoffman and
candice bergen and simon hellberg from
big bang theory and diana agron and that
is our um our main cast for
this movie it's out on on demand um it's
showing in some theaters but it's mainly
like an on space
to get a movie about your you know you
were basically just journaling for your
mental health it was elaborate
journaling but yes
but that's basically what it is and then
and then now you're on the set directing
dustin hoffman i mean it's crazy
and that brings me back to the word
accomplishment
you know it's like the phd of show
business
isn't it
isn't it
maybe maybe an associate arts degree
maybe a master's
see i find it so interesting that you
ended up going back into show business
not that you left and went into school
and decided to do something else and
then after that you went back into show
business because what i find most
interesting and what i connect with is
you talk a lot about
you feeling really uncomfortable like in
this setting in show business right
because you're really out there and
you're with people and you have to
socialize
and so and i feel that all the time when
i when i have to socialize or be out
there and it's so hard for me so to make
that choice to go back
into show business
seems like it would be a hard decision
or a struggle why did you decide to do
that um it it it was a very
you know it's a difficult decision when
i think about how much the industry has
changed you know um there wasn't like
social media
you know my last go-around um 14 year
olds could look 14 no one was asking us
to get hair extensions or manicures like
it was just such a different time
especially for young girls um the god's
honest truth is that i had finished grad
school i had my first son in grad school
and my second right after i took my
doctoral degree eight months seven
months pregnant um i have was running
out of health insurance this is the true
story i was teaching neuroscience for
about five years after getting my degree
i taught um two homeschoolers junior
high in high school neuroscience uh
biology i taught i taught a little
chemistry it's not my strength and uh i
was tutoring piano i was tutoring hebrew
i was doing everything to make ends meet
um we were running out of insurance and
i said you know i've never really done
this as an adult
if i can just get literally a couple
guest spots enough to get
health insurance i mean i had a toddler
and a newborn you know i mean it's kind
of it's a weird story but like this is
america you know i was running out of
health insurance
i did not the father did not get me the
father of these the father didn't uh
contribute or doesn't have health
insurance
um we were both grad students we met in
college we were both grad students and
we were both on the same stipend system
and they do not continue your insurance
after he got his master's and i got my
doctorate
so um
what what i did is i
started auditioning just for like you
know i did an episode of bones i don't
think my character even had a name like
i did an episode of saving grace and i
had never seen the big bang theory i
didn't know what it was
um i never thought i'd be a regular on a
tv show again like that's not what my
life plan was like i had long hippie
chick hair i don't even know what size
clothes i wore because it's just like
whatever um
i mean i was like i hadn't squeezed my
eyebrows ever
i was like a normal person in santa cruz
i know
that's right and we went to we both went
to ucla too i went to ucla as well oh
yeah
yes the bruins but but it is interesting
to hear that somebody pursued even if it
was the second time this career most
people who pursue it will pursue it in
wrongly probably but for the success for
fame and recognition
and money and stardom but you just
wanted a good health plan
i just wanted some health coverage right
that's why people end up working in
factories and to you this is a show
business factory
[Music]
you